well gentlemen it's hard to believe 25
years ago this week my first guest was
elected the 42nd president of the United
States which led to the longest period
of peacetime expansion in American
history we are honored to have him join
us here in Harlem tonight please welcome
President Bill Clinton
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa
you were great at trivia you thought you
thought you think I have you think I
have a future at Silvius is how you're
saying but I have one question yeah did
they let you keep the hairnet that's not
a good look for me it's really not a
good look for me it was so cool what
look it's a great place yes you've been
there you've eaten there question oh
yeah many times it's great yeah and
they're great people
yeah and it's part of what makes Harlem
special yes my office is like two blocks
from here yeah yeah you know I couldn't
believe I couldn't believe in the
introduction you were elected president
it's time to strange things 25 years ago
this week 25 years ago this week and the
first question I had was what was the
hardest thing to get used to on the
first day that you were no longer
president as a civilian cuz that's got
to be a massive change what was the
hardest thing to get used to they don't
play a song when you walk in the room in
the weeks I was totally lost I know
where I was held in the - yeah yeah you
know you could probably work it out so
they play it for you can't let a little
boom box and just push a button when you
come into a room yeah but then if you
think you're still there that's really
dangerous
you